hi there so today I just wanted to bring
you a quick coding tip that I often
encounter in my daily machine learning
researcher life
that might not be super common in let's
say traditional software engineering or
elsewhere so often I have a bunch of
let's say of a bunch of models right and
I use these ipython notebooks or colapse
to analyze my data plot things and so on
so I have a bunch of models let's say
they're called M one and M two and I
usually run my big jobs on a cluster so
let's say I have run some jobs for one
for each model and have some logs that I
want to analyze so I'll go through my
models and I here I you know load a
bunch of logs and I'll also compute some
stuff some statistics and some just
things right that I wanna what I have
computed and maybe these things are
called a and let's this and B right so
now I've computed these things now I
want to analyze them and let's let's
short cut and say printing is plotting
so think of these this might be numbers
right and now I want to plot them here
out let's just print them which I do
this now every time I want to you know
change something here in my printing
maybe I am
I want the separator to be that I'll
have to load all the logs and compute
all the stuff right each time I run this
cell which is not super cool right so I
usually would like to factor out the
plotting and and stuff like this from
the computation so I could extract one
of them into like a function but then at
the point of these notebooks is that I
can run each of the cells and they'll
run right there right so functions
aren't really cool in these notebooks so
what I'll usually end up doing is you'll
have some second loop in here right and
let's see you'll have some data
up here and you here at the end you'll
something say something like data for
this model is a
and and B or something like this right
and then down here the first thing I do
is I get my data and then I'll unpack
again so da DB either a long pack or
I'll just address them in dictionary
notation like this and then I can do my
plotting right some people use tuples
here right they could just go a and B
but then you'll have to do this
unpacking the problem is now if I want
to add something here I write I compute
something new I now need to add
something here right I need to remember
to store it in the data array and then I
need to here remember to unpack it in
the same order right and then I need to
produce to put it in in the plotting
right so this this is very cumbersome
this line here and this line here
they're very because you kind of
duplicate your own variable names all
over the place just because you want to
compute them here and use them here a
software engineer would usually tell you
let's do something like a data class or
or in in its most simplest form is say a
class and you know there are multiple
ways of achieving this but let's just do
a and B here this is more probably the
most verbose you can also do name two
posts outer classes data classes and so
on but ultimately you produce a class
like this and then here you say this is
a data class a and B and then here down
here you can at least address them like
this right and and you don't have to do
the data dictionary notation or remember
the remember the the the order but now
again if you want to add the C no you
know not only do you have to add it here
but you have to add it up here and you
have to add it here and
beware if there's a doc string and then
you can use it here right this is just
I'd is too cumbersome so here it is a
trick and please only use these in like
notebooks like this this will lead to so
much memory problems and everything and
if you work with a software engineer you
might have to get them chocolate for
doing this but but alright so what you
can do is you can save your local
variables in the in this dictionary
right so this is a built-in that saves
the local variables I'm sorry that gives
you a dict of the local variables the
local variables here are ABC m and all a
bunch of other things right it's not
clearing these ipython notebooks they
have a bunch of stuff around them such
that the meaning is slightly different
depending where locals is but in essence
you'll get the a B and C what you want
now the locals dict refers in order for
this to go through the local stick
refers of course is the same objects not
newly constructed so we're safe here to
make a copy of that right like this and
then down here we simply retrieve these
local variables and update the current
local variables using the local
variables we stored and voila we can use
a B and C without ever having to find
them right if this doesn't work that
means that the locals here are is is a
copy basically and this is a python
optimization and i read i don't have to
use it because in these ipython
notebooks it appears to work but you
might want to have an empty exact
statement here such that the Python
interpreter can never be sure which
variables are created in here and
therefore can't optimize away so that
that is a horrible horrible trick again
don't
anything serious upon this but it is
very duper super easy you can just add
any variable here and then use it down
here so easy right and so wrong
alright this was it I hope you enjoyed
this I want to bring these kind of tips
every now and then as an intermix into
the research papers I hope you enjoy
this bye bye